ich freue mich nicht darüber dass
neonazis sind der deutschlandpolitik
sich herum treiben können die hat
versucht sich mal in einem ersten
schritt von diesen rechtsradikalen und
neonazis zu befreien das ist ihr nicht
gelungen das zeigt wie tief in dieser
partei verankert der rechtsradikalismus
ist ich habe weder schadenfreude noch
sonst irgendwas dafür finde dass
abscheulich dass solche leute in der
deutschen politik zu hause sind die
ideologien vertreten die zu den
schlimmsten verbrechen der menschheit
geführt haben von daher kann ich nur
hoffen dass die in der afd sich nicht
entmutigen lassen die an klaren
trennungsstrich zwischen sehr
konservativen positionen von mir aus
auch deutschnationalen positionen und
echten faschisten und neonazis haben
wollen
den kann man nur sagen dass sie diesen
kampf fortführen müssen
herr bosbach was sagt das über eine
partei aus dass sie ihre rechte ssten
leute nicht los wird
das sind für die momente in denen hans
olaf henkel und bern luca handelt froh
sind dass sie fluchtartig das weite
gesucht haben nachdem die beiden leider
aus ihrer sicht feststellen mussten dass
eben die afg nicht zu einer partei für
enttäuschte konservative wird sondern
für stramme rechtsradikalen dass die
mittlerweile doch den ton angeben es
geht nicht nur um herrn kalbitz was
glauben sie wie viele katzen es
mittlerweile in der ard gibt und wie
viele kalbitz doch den ton angeben aber
drin bleibt oder aber ausgeschlossen ist
ist nicht besonders relevant denn alle
die die meinen wenn kalbitz weg ist und
röcke in seiner bedeutung politisch
reduziert wird dann bekommen wir eine
andere af.de werden sich wundern jörg
abels und co haben längst das ruder in
der afc in der hand